bien la parole est à madame denise
saint-pé pour le groupe union centriste
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
certains s'inquiètent aujourd'hui qu'un
black out énergétique surviennent en
france cependant un tel scénario ne
pourrait se produire qu'en réduisant
plusieurs conditions
d'une part une forte hausse de la
consommation d'électricité elles mêmes
liées à une baisse durable des
températures et d'autre part une absence
de vent à même d'empêcher le parc éolien
de prendre le relais du parc nucléaire
le risque me paraît donc limité pour le
moment et je compte sur le gouvernement
pour faire en sorte qu'ils ne se
réalisent pas cependant je souhaiterais
aborder la question sur le moyen terme
en réalité des tensions existent déjà
aujourd'hui au moment des pics de
consommation et pourrait bientôt
s'amplifier un effet nos capacités de
production nationales disponibles lors
de ces pointes de consommation risquent
de diminuer à l'avenir puisque 14
réacteurs nucléaires devront être fermés
pour atteindre les objectifs fixés par
la ppe à savoir une part du nucléaire de
50% dans le mix énergétique français
d'ici 2035
ces fermetures devrait être en principe
compensé par un recours accru aux
énergies renouvelables
néanmoins une compensation complète et
efficace laisse dubitatif car ces
sources d'énergie sont par nature
intermittente et produisent moins que le
nucléaire
rajoutons à cette équation le fait que
la r e 2020 restreindra de fait
l'utilisation du gaz dans les logements
neufs
cela conduira au retour du chauffage
électrique ce qui risque de solliciter
encore plus nos capacités de production
d'électricité par conséquent comment
pensez vous concilier demain à la fois
la baisse de la ressource électriques
disponibles au moment des pics de
consommation et l'augmentation plus que
pour
bah bhl de la demande d'anne électricité
et ce sans risquer des black out
hivernaux répéter je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre merci madame la
présidente monsieur les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice sempé la politique
énergétique du gouvernement elle va
permettre d'avoir un système électrique
plus diversifiée on l'a dit qui sera
donc plus résilient face aux aléas
l'attention sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de cet hiver à
l'illustrer il me semble très bien ces
risques d'un système qui ne reposerait
massivement que sur une seule
technologie
cette diversification du mix elle est en
particulier et en particulier dans le
programme de fermeture des réacteurs
dans le développement des énergies
renouvelables qui est ambitieux mais
progressif il ne met pas en péril la
sécurité d'approvisionnement
ce constat il s'appuie sur des analyses
techniques approfondies menées par rte
qui intègre les prévisions d'évolution
de la production de la demande et du
fonctionnement du réseau pour la
production rte intègre la modélisation
d'un très grand nombre de situations
notamment les aléas météo les aléas sur
les moyens de production comme les
retards de maintenance et s'agissant de
l'aéro 20 20 celles ci s'appliquent à
des logements neufs donc ayant une
consommation faible puisque bien isolé
nous mais non nous menons donc une
politique très volontariste de
rénovation des bâtiments existants pour
limiter les besoins de chauffage et le
développement de solutions de chauffage
qui soit peu consommatrices d'énergie
comme les pompes à chaleur la géothermie
les réseaux de chaleur décarbonés sont
évidemment encouragé il n'est ainsi pas
anticipé d'augmentation de la
consommation électrique dans les
prochaines années
or concernant les évolutions au delà de
2035 le ministère la transition
écologique a demandé à l'eeie et rte une
étude sur les enjeux liés à
l'intégration massive d'énergies
renouvelables variable dans le système
électrique
les résultats sont très encourageants
ils doivent être publiés sous peu et une
analyse plus détaillée de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement à horizon 2050 doit
être publié à la mi 2021 par rte dans le
cadre de son bilan prévisionnel de long
terme
ces études elles permettront de prendre
des décisions éclairées
sur l'évolution de notre mix après 2035
en toute connaissance de ces différents
enjeux y compris ceux liés à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
merci